surprise to the oculus six hundred
dollar price tag yeah me too especially
as it was billed as being in the $350
ballpark well oculus found a palmer
luckey has taken to reddit where else to
apologize for misleading consumers and
explain where those figures came from
I'm Lucy and welcome to this number
crunching gamespot news update in his
ask me anything bread lucky confess that
when he was making such estimates about
the oculus rift price being close to
three hundred fifty dollars it was
actually known to him internally that
the price would be closer to six hundred
it appears that his explanation for
misleading people was a means to counter
another falsehood that the oculus rift
would cost somewhere close to $1,500
lucky said I handled the messaging for
Lane earlier last year we started
officially messaging that the rift with
a recommended spec PC wood together cost
roughly fifteen hundred dollars many
outlets take the story up as rift will
cost fifteen hundred dollars then in a
sep tember interview during the oculus
connect developer conference I made the
infamous roughly in that 350 ballpark
but it will cost more than that quote as
an explanation not an excuse during that
time many outlets were repeating the
rift is $1,500 line and I was frustrated
by how many people thought that that was
the price of the headset itself he went
on to explain that when making his
infamous estimate he was aware that his
six hundred dollar price tag was more
likely my answer was ill-prepared and
mentally I was contrasting three hundred
and forty nine dollars with 1,500 not
our internal estimate that hop at close
to 5 99 that is why I said it was
roughly in the same ballpark pre-orders
for the rift went live yesterday as it
consumers reactions to the steeper than
anticipated price tag lucky said the
price was obscenely cheap considering
the technology packaged in each device
now claimed that each unit cells at a
loss but then lucky appeared to show
regret for mismanaging expectations
later on after the $350 claims I tried
to get across that the risk would cost
more than many expected in the past two
weeks particularly there are a lot of
reasons we do not do a better job of
prepping people who already have
high-end GPUs legal financial
competitive and otherwise but to be
perfectly honest
our biggest failing was assuming we had
been clear enough about setting
expectations another problem is that
people looked at the much less advanced
technology in dk2 for three hundred and
fifty dollars and assumed the consumer
Rick would cost a similar amount an
assumption that myself and oculus did
not do a good job of fixing I apologize
it's six hundred dollars too much to pay
for virtual reality let me know in the
comments box below I'll come find me on
Twitter I'm at Lucy James games for all
the latest on virtual reality make sure
to keep it gamespot